our experiences are not descriptions of
the world they're not like mirrors of
the world they are a causal response to
the world
[Music]
I'm Hillary Lawson I'm the founder of
The Institute of Art and ideas and I'm a
non-realist philosopher I'm interested
in
metaphysics and the big overall story
that we uh use to describe the world
and on your non-realist philosophy what
is closure Theory
well we've tended to think that most
people imagine that the world is
something out there and it's divided
into bits
and the puzzle of life is to work out
what those bits are and indeed the
puzzle for human knowledge has been to
try and work out what those bits are
and I think that we've in the 20th
century discovered that we can't
actually arrive at an account of of what
is out there because we are embedded in
a perspective and there are an
indefinite number of perspectives
and so I take the rather surprising
starting point that let's consider the
world not as being something that's
divided into bits but is something other
it's some unspecified other
and that what we do is we close this and
what I call this unspecified other
openness to avoid us thinking that
something in particular and we close the
openness of the world
into our ideas of thoughts and things
and properties and so forth and what we
do in the in the closing of the openness
of a world is we give ourselves ways of
intervening
but at the same time we sort of cut
ourselves off from the openness so it's
a sort of two-way exercise that we need
closures in order to intervene but
um are they also in a way
take us further away from openness so
you know if you just take any uh any
object
um maybe if you just pass me the uh
bottle there it'll be they'll be nice so
if you take a a an example of this
bottle
um you might say well it's a it's a
bottle and by doing that it means that
we can do things with it you can ask me
what sort of bottle it is you can ask me
to pass the bottle you can say what's in
it you can say where was it manufactured
you ask all sorts of things about what
it is
but um you might say you might describe
it not as a bottle at all you might
describe it as a weapon
um in which case it's wool is an
ineffective weapon uh does it does it uh
does it do the damage that you intended
it to you might say it's
um a environmental disaster
in which case you would say well just
how dangerous is is an environmental
disaster you know where does it fall on
the scale if you were a physicist you
might describe it in terms of its
molecular structure
so all of these different ways of
holding this bit of the world are
closures I would say they're ways of
closing openness and the stuff the
openness this whatever's there is all of
these things it's like the potential to
hold them in those ways so I think we
have to give up the idea that there's
there are bits out there that we name
and instead thinking of the world as
being open that we close and those
closures have value and they can be
refined and they can get better but
they're not somehow an ultimate
description they're a way of holding the
world rather than uh being How It
ultimately is so if we can't avoid
closing off the world
but it means that that openness escapes
us what is the point in trying to
understand the world
because we can refine our closures
once we've chosen one we can ask all
sorts of questions about it so as I was
saying if we hold something in a
particular way we say well what sort of
example of this is what sort of bottle
is this is what sort of new uh person
this is what whatever the closure is so
we refine those closures and those
closures then enable us to do more
so the attempt to
deepen our closures and make them
achieve the outcome that is where we
what we want from them to to enable us
to use that frame that vocabulary in a
way that's valuable is immensely
powerful it's just that I think that we
shouldn't
uh
think that
they are
an ultimate description of the world
they're a way of holding it and there's
an indefinite number of other ways of
holding it
uh which have different qualities and
different values and I think also the
other thing is that closure is never the
same as openness it's a different sort
of stuff I think it's a category mistake
to think they're the same sort of thing
they're just different sorts of things
so if you look closely at whatever the
closure is it will never be as the world
is so you can always find ways in which
your closure fails they're always going
to fail there's never going to be a
closure where we say oh yeah we've got
we've sorted it now it's always an
infinite Gap between closure and
openness but
trying to refine them and make them more
effective for whatever purpose we want
for is an immensely valuable exercise
just as is finding the ways in which
they don't work
I think the idea that we close off the
world in these ways would sound familiar
to a lot of people but could you explain
what openness is yes
so
you have to provide some sense I'm not
I'm a not I'm a non-realist so I'm a
Critic of the idea that our ideas
reflect things that are out there in the
world
so the question is what's the
alternative to realism
and
I would describe myself therefore as a
post-realist or a non-realist
and that's because I can't
tell you what is going on other as it
were than realism I can't say well it's
like this because if I could then I
would be my uh you know I would be a
realist again I would be telling you
that's what it is out there
but it seems to me that our experiences
are not descriptions of the world
they're not like mirrors of the world
they are a causal response to the world
so when your eye responds to the world
and your own fires you know one of the
100 million neurons whatever fires well
that neuron is responding in one
particular way to everything that's out
there
so it takes all of the openness of the
world and it does one thing
and we hold the world as that one thing
so it will it I mean in fact of course
we hold all a whole load of neurons
together as say a patch of blue and all
of those neurons won't be firing in
exactly the way the same way and they
won't be blue but what we do is we hold
things as as a single thing but the
world's nothing to do with that thing
it's not a description it's a closure
um so when I use the word openness I am
would be saying that it's an unspecified
oven and I'm not saying that there's no
there's nothing out there it's all in
our heads there's plenty of stuff out
there but it's not differentiated it's
not you know it's language that
differentiates things into objects and
things and properties and you know all
of that sort of stuff but what's out
there is a different sort of thing and
the way of trying to give an idea of
what it's like to say well let's just
imagine that it's an unspecified other
on a way of thinking about it so
thinking it is being open and full of
potential and we we close that potential
with our closures but we can't if I
could tell you what openness was then I
wouldn't be a non-realist I would be a
realist again and I think we just have
to give up the idea that we can say as
it were How It ultimately is in favor of
this this account which enables I think
a way of understanding why it is we have
different perspectives why people can
have such radically different views and
all think they're right
um and and indeed to point to perhaps
you know other ways that we could
interact so that we can try and stand in
the place of other perspectives rather
than thinking that there's a correct
answer
um and somebody's got it wrong and
somebody's got it right
if perspectives become refined over time
we thought and Truth what are they being
refined towards well I think that we are
we are alive and we are trying to
operate in the world and so our closures
are designed to help us do what we want
to do and I think we want to do all
sorts of things you know I could say
Well it helps us achieve the goals that
we want but maybe
um we want to feel relaxed and not be
focused on it you know there's an
indefinite number of things that we can
be wanting to achieve with our closures
and I think the the role of them is to
is to enable us to get an outcome that
we are we're wanting to achieve of
course we we fail a lot of the time in
doing that
and personally have you felt that
recognizing the openness of the world
has made you able to accept other
perspectives more
well I certainly think the framework
of openness and closure has influenced
the way that I think about
everything and the way that I interact
the world and I think it does mean that
you have a way of being able to make
sense of what otherwise seems to be a
very conflictual and chaotic world and
somebody at the festival said to me
today you know that they had they had
found closure really useful for them in
that way that on a personal level they
had felt that
um it had just enabled them to have much
more feeling for what was going on
in your work you've experimented with
using visual means
you could explain a bit more about how
you've done that the reason for that was
that I
uh had had experience I mean my career
has been split between an academic one
and the engagement with philosophy and
uh uh one in programming and making uh
making programs and documentaries and so
I had the experience of filming events
and I wondered whether there was a way
when you film something you're always
looking for narrative I think what's
Happening Here is it somebody crossing a
road is it a burglary is it what am I
trying to convey what's the narrative
and as viewers we are always trying to
spot that narrative and we have
thousands of hours of experience of
trying to spot the narratives in in
images
so I wondered whether there was a way
that we could film things that uh
enabled us not to engage in closure
could you film something which didn't
somehow tell you how to look at it
and so I was intrigued by that idea and
thought well maybe there is a way of
doing which avoids narratives so the
early video paintings that were
generated were of images of thing moving
images of things where you might
be tempted to think oh this is a picture
of a sky or of a river but in fact there
are lots of layers of movement going on
and you sort of fight with your desire
for closure what's happening is
something going to come by is this a
picture of a canoe you know what what
what what's going to happen in this
picture of a a river but in but it
doesn't close in that sort of way and
um so that's how the uh the video
painting movement developed from those
initial ideas and in some ways I think
it reflects what I think happens in in
other areas of art so poetry for example
avoids closure if you had a poem like
yeah a line of a poem like oh Rose Thou
Art sick and somebody said well actually
what this means is the the rose that's a
flower you know it's got some disease
this would not be perjury the whole
point of poetry is it's open
as soon as you close it into a meaning
it's no longer poetry it's it's a
description it's not what it is and so
uh I think that
I wondered whether we could do that with
uh video and film could we in a sense
create poetry on film and that's what we
were trying to do and do you think you
were successful in being able to do that
I think some of the uh some of the
strongest most interesting video
paintings certainly do that yes
created that video
not be narrative in it but there's
definite control of what the viewer is
seeing of course and more than that I
mean we attached
um titles to the image which are of
course forms of closure but
the strange way that openness and
closure work is that if you just are in
openness
which some people try and attain so
there are obviously movements in art
which were like white on white images
you know like trying to have nothing in
the frame
um and uh I guess there are forms of you
know meditation which are engaged in
trying to have nothing you know to avoid
all closure as it were so
um but if you try and avoid closure
altogether then
um certainly as an art form you are left
with nothing
and you but you sort of like have
everything and nothing
and you have to close to some degree in
order to be able to be engaged in that
transition
so I think maybe a more refined version
of what I was saying before would be
that we are on the cusp of openness and
closure and we find a way to to play
with those oppositions in order to have
the outcomes that we're looking for and
so as well as
well as of your work what about in the
realm of politics we're used to hearing
that it's a very divided time or tribal
time does your theory of pleasure have a
part to play in politics today well
it certainly I think changes one's
approach in the sense that I would try
to encourage a dialogue between people
that didn't assume that there was a
right answer
at the very idea of someone thinking you
know my story is the only one you know
this is this is the truth is I think a
dangerous notion and what we should try
and do is stand in the place of other
people the enclosures are metaphors for
the world and I think that we should try
and stand in the in the place of a
another person's metaphor if you like
and explore it and that doesn't mean to
say we accept it
so we may think no no I I don't like
this metaphor at all I don't like its
consequences have you considered that it
means this have you considered how does
it account for this issue over here you
know how does it work so it's not that
it it stops there being dispute of
course there's going to be dispute we're
going to have different uh ways that we
want to hold the world but I think it
does encourage a engagement with an
alternative perspective and it also
allows for a proliferation of
perspectives you know that that it's not
like well there's a correct way to see
things that that there are different
perspectives but I wouldn't say that all
perspectives are equally valid uh I
think that we have to get inside those
perspectives and see what they're like
and then and then see do we like the do
we like using them you know if we like
using them and they achieve the outcomes
that we want and it has an outcome for
the world that we want well you know
that's that's a good perspective
um so uh yes I think it does have
consequences yeah
and is there one thinker that's been
particularly important for you in your
own philosophy and work well I would say
there's there's one thinker I was
responding to the primary
uh figures in 20th century philosophies
so
my own Outlook
um was a consequence of seeing what I
thought had happened with uh
Wittgenstein
and indeed where Continental figures
like derida and previously in the late
19th century figures like nature
Heidegger of how they had tried to deal
with the problem of uh the nature of the
world and I felt that most of those
figures that I've mentioned
had come to a view
that we couldn't describe how things
were
but they didn't offer a description of
how we should hold it and they didn't do
that because they felt they were trapped
in a self-referential puzzle that if
they said how they thought the world was
they would somehow be trying to do
something they couldn't do you know
they'd come to the conclusion that
language couldn't describe the world and
therefore the thing to do was somehow
avoid saying how it actually was
and well that's that's one version of it
if we can start I think was certainly in
that position in his later work derada
may be engaged in a constant
deconstruction of any any offer offering
that you did put forward uh Nietzsche
engaged in a certain sort of Anarchy of
suggesting lots of different ones so
they have different responses to this
over over or Insight that we can't
really say How It ultimately is and I
was
um
both convinced by the first bit that we
can't say how things ultimately are but
was unhappy with the idea that we should
just avoid saying anything at all as a
result because I think that we can't
achieve that in any case I think that
um you know figures like vikken and
Stein and derida we only really
understand their position by giving them
an overall metaphysical position which
they are refusing to state if if we
really take them at face value and we we
take them as avoiding any position at
all then well what are they saying and
and so I thought no we we have to try
and give an account of our circumstances
even though we know that it will be in
some sense temporary and will in some
sense fail but it's as good as we can do
at the moment
and so so I think all of those figures
have been you know very influential for
me in trying to uh frame how I think uh
we might go about making sense of the
world now
for more debates talks and interviews so
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas our AI TV